foreign
Josh how are you
I'm good how are you today better than
we deserve sir how can we help
good um before I start I just want to
say God bless you all guys and thank you
so much I've been watching a lot of your
videos here recently and I'm working on
the baby steps well thank you sir we're
honored to have you in the audience how
can we help today
um right me and my wife are halfway
um going to baby step one and I had a
car problem I got my car paid off a year
ago but it's
it blew up and I need a new vehicle that
I'll have the
cash saved to just buy one and I'm I'm
gonna try well I I and I'm becoming very
anti-death too but the only way I know
how to do that is
a small car loans under 10 000
preferably seven
do you don't have any money
uh nothing saved up okay what's the car
the car you were driving what was it
worth before it blew up
uh I don't know the Kelly's Blue Book it
was a 2007 Toyota Camry
okay so what would you think it was
worth what would you guess
I think I could probably sells around
three thousand before it blew up yes sir
okay all right so there's no need to get
a seven thousand dollar car then you
were driving a three before this
happened
right okay so we could buy a three
thousand dollar car and break even let's
start with that what's your household
income
all right we uh a month we uh bring in
four thousand four hundred and eleven
dollars okay good and how much is your
rent
uh we don't have renter mortgage my wife
inherited to their house by our
grandfather who passed away a few years
ago that's good news okay and uh both of
you work outside the home
yes sir okay
and and you currently have one car
that's running right
yeah it is it's online it's my wife's
truck it's uh we pay 475 a month for it
okay so it's got a loan on it but you
own you own one other car a 500 car
payment on a four thousand dollar
take-home pay ouch that's no fun
um
and uh you don't uh you don't own
another car right you don't own a third
car do you
no sir okay
what's your tractor worth
I don't know what's your lawnmower worth
there's gonna be your own bears and
don't have a loan okay it's not
embarrassing what would be embarrassing
is if you told me you had a seven
thousand dollar zero turn that would be
embarrassing okay because I'd be selling
it to buy you a car okay so you're doing
good Josh you're passing the test so far
you've got a lot of common sense I'm
just looking around here because
sometimes sometimes I just got married
five months ago okay good very good so
you married this car payment okay
okay
um what do you do for a living
I'm a housekeeper at a university okay
and my wife is my wife's a welder at a
factory excellent excellent okay all
right so your car with the blown engine
will probably bring 1500 at the salvage
yard maybe more
I hope so that would be a lot more than
I was thinking yeah a thousand to
fifteen hundred it'll bring uh or
someone will give you that because he's
going to put an engine in it okay
um yeah I don't want you to put an
engine in it you don't you don't fix
three thousand dollar cars those are
throwaway cars okay right
um
so I'll tell you the you can go the
route you wanted to go but I wouldn't
recommend it and you're brand new to our
stuff so our stuff can sometimes feel
awfully extreme but one of the things I
found is if I'm going to break a series
of bad habits or principles in my life I
have to adopt the extreme to complete
the transformation in my heart okay so
when we went broke Josh I drove a
borrowed car for four months I'm not
suggesting you have a car you can borrow
but I'm just telling you how what I did
okay what I did was I drove a 1978
Cadillac with 478 000 actual miles on it
the predominant color was Bondo and the
vinyl roof was torn loose across the
front so when you drove it it filled up
with air and looked like a parachute on
a Bondo buggy it was the most
embarrassing hillbilly car you can think
of
and I drove that car for three months
one ten year period
it's what it felt like 10 years it felt
like 10 years it was only three months
but buddy I saved some money during that
three months because I'm getting rid of
Bondo buggy right highly motivated
that's what I was
so I'm gonna suggest you do something
weird like that like let's sell this car
for 1500 and go buy a fifteen hundred
dollar car that runs and drive it for
four months and during that four months
oh you can buy it it's a garage sale car
it's ugly it's got a hail dents in it
but it runs oh you want is something
that runs